alternativement au départ c'est
l'initiative d'une association by sea
qui à bayonne au pays basque
pratique à haute dose la subversion du
système par le détournement humoristique
et non violents en 2013
alternativa est passé aux
contre-propositions pour offrir des
alternatives concrètes et ce fut un
village entre guillemets qui à bayonne
réunit douze mille personnes
devant ce succès alternative assez mis
en route en vélo bien sûr pour cinq
mille six cents kilomètres d'un tour de
france qui à saint laurent des eaux a
fait la jonction avec ceux qui dans le
loiret proposent des alternatives au
tout nucléaire
arrivée de l'étape le composant tôt à
orléans pour un village alternative à
décentraliser
parmi ces visiteurs ont pu y rencontrer
par exemple un jeune architecte
paysagiste
j'essaie autant que faire se peut
d'avoir un certain nombre de valeurs
dans la manière dont je fais mon métier
donc évidemment l'écologie travaille
avec des matériaux circuits courts avoir
travaillé sur l'aménagement du
territoire
ça amène un certain nombre de questions
parce que on peut travailler sur des
espaces géants rien avec le social par
exemple les maisons de retraite au genre
de choses il colore gelé pour how
composantes ou s'informer sur l'activité
du monde associatif et alternatifs de la
région c'est une vitrine des
alternatives concrètes locales qui sont
les solutions pour le changement
climatique les solutions locales ici qui
sont déjà en route on à 65 stand
aujourd'hui donc il ya énormément de
gens on a des maisons en paille on a des
amap on a des jardins partagés on a
plein de choses des gens qui font
localement quelque chose on espère
montrer au national qu'en local on fait
plein de choses que s'il ya plein de
choses existe et on espère que qui
sortira quelque chose de cette comme 21
à paris en 2000 en décembre 2004 ce soir
le two interactive a sera chartres au
coeur de cette agriculture productiviste
qui le remet en cause avant de
s'installer à paris pour rappeler aux
décideurs réunis dans la coque 21
l'exigence d'un futur possible et pour
lequel ils proposent leurs solutions